yale university once considered our
nation's foremost home
of patriarchy and wasp culture has
apparently changed its tune
in recent years as evidenced by a recent
lecture
during which a leftist psychiatrist
described her desire to
shoot white guys this is the cost of
talking to white people at all
the cost of your own life has been
[ __ ] dry there are no good apples
okay why people make my blood boil
and the fantasies of us loading a
revolver into the head
of any white person that got in my way
gearing their body
and wiping my bloody hands as i walked
away relatively differently
with a bounce on myself
white males that's going to be the new
the new alma mater of yale apparently
meanwhile donald trump another white
male who
gets booted from facebook for another
two years joe biden ignores d-day to
harp on the tulsa race riot
and we investigate what america can
learn from nigeria
there act there is something actually
nigeria might be a little more
politically serious these days
than the united states how's that i'm
michael knowles this is the michael show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday
is from fable nuclear reactor who says
breaking news
after the leaked emails dr fauci now
recommends face masks over your eyes
this is true it's amazing how that works
you know
but definitely over your mouth and now
with the emails it's more important
actually
to put it over your eyes see no evil
maybe over your ears hear no evil
over your mouth too i actually have a
runner-up favorite comment from friday
we don't always do this but i
i thought this was so insightful that i
had to read it out
from billy s who says i bet everyone who
voted for joe biden
are rolling over in their graves right
now and i think that's probably true i
assume they were rolling in their graves
when they ostensibly voted for him
if you want to protect yourself you got
to check out
ring very important to protect your home
how do you do it
you got a ring this is a great way to
know who is at your door before you open
that door
because it could be anybody forget about
it could be a burglar so i guess it
could
but it could be the pizza guy you're
going to want to know that it could be
someone dropping off packages you're
going to want to know that you're going
to run to the door and open it up it
could be
your mother-in-law in which case maybe
you start running you stop
then you stay perfectly still nobody
sees nobody moves
great way to get peace of mind when i'm
on the road i love knowing that sweet
little elise and cute little june
will know who is outside the door before
they open that door and by the way you
can see and speak to
whoever's outside the door whether
you're in the house whether you're at
your office
whether you're on another continent
ring is the way to do it also makes a
great housewarming gift
because it's cool and it's great product
people want it
and it's not that expensive i love that
so you get credit for a great gift
without shelling out a lot of money
start protecting your home today with
ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles to get your ring alarm security
kit today you can build the system
that's right for you
have it up and running in minutes that
is ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles tough out there for a white guy
these days apparently
if you think of a white guy can't walk
down the streets of new haven at yale
without being threatened with a gun
then really something has gone crazy in
this country
now anybody walks down the streets of
new haven and gets threatened with a gun
that
that's sort of ordinary but generally
our view of yale right is this is the
patriarchy this is the wasp culture
this is where the white men wield their
power
over the society and that's not really
true that i don't
if it ever was true it certainly isn't
true now now
lecturers give whole talks at yale
university
unironically about how they want to
shoot white men it's not as though this
was just an example used as a kind of
ironic joke but then she's realized that
she shouldn't do this
no she was being very earnest she thinks
that white men are deserving of
violent death at her hands and it's not
just this kind of
insane i mean it is insane she's an
insane woman but
it's not just an emotional outburst she
actually made
an argument the talk is called the
psychopathic problem of the white mind
and this psychopath who gave the talk
decided to project and accuse her
opponents of that
that uh thing from which she she suffers
this was given at the yale school of
medicine's
child study center and the the woman's
name is dr
aruna kilani and
here is her argument the white people
are out of their minds they have been
for a long time
so remember the psychological
predicament because
when people feel that we are bullying
them when we bring up rape
they feel that we should be thanking
them for all that they have done for us
they are confused and so are we
can you hear me okay yeah
okay we keep forgetting that directly
talking about race is a waste of our
breath
we are asking a demented a violent
predator
who thinks that they're a state or a
superhero to accept responsibility
it ain't gonna happen they have five
holes in their brain
it's like banging your head against a
brick wall just like sure is not a good
idea
we need to remember that directly
talking about race to white people is
useless
because we're at the wrong level of
conversation
addressing racism assumes that like
people can see and process
what we are talking about they can't
that's why they sound demented
they don't even know they have a mask on
white people think it's their actual
face
we need to get to know them so the first
point which is obvious
within seconds of listening to this
woman is that everything that she
accuses
white people of being and doing
she herself is and does right so she
calls white people demented this woman
is clearly demented
she accuses white people of being
incapable of rational thought
she herself is not only incapable of
rational thought
at the moment at least but she denies
the possibility of rational thought
right and and so
beyond her insane babbling there is
an argument here it's an argument that
stops arguments
we often talk about the chesterton quote
there's a thought that stops
thought and that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped she is expressing
that right here
and the reason i bring it up is not just
because some insane lady said something
crazy at yale if that's all we focused
on then that would be the subject of the
show every single day
because there are plenty examples of
that the the reason i bring it up is
because this is
what we're talking about when we talk
about critical race theory
not just the obsession with sex or race
rather
not just there's also sexual politics
which we'll get to a little bit later
it's not just the obsession with race
it's not just the vilification of people
on the basis of their race namely white
people
it's more importantly the denial
of rational thought the denial of our
ability to understand things whenever
you hear
these radical leftists talking about how
you
you can't deny my lived experience and
you can never
know what it is to suffer this sort of
oppression
and you can never empathize and you know
what they're saying is you don't have
perception conception faculties of
reason you're not
capable of intellect and and furthermore
when when she says it's a waste of
breath to talk about these things to
white people
she's expressing a central tenet of
this kind of critical race theory or
critical theory or the broader
20th century sort of neo-marxist
tradition namely
that we are going to deny
objective reality and in so doing we're
going to deny
that the words which refer to objective
reality have any meaning
this is actually at the very heart of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words because available now for
pre-order
the idea that because there's no such
thing as objective reality there's no
such thing as nature to which we're
bound
and this actually on the sex point
relates to transgenderism because it
means we're not even bound to
our very own sexual nature but because
there's no objective thing that we're
bound to
then words can just mean whatever we
want them to it's like humpty dumpty in
alice in wonderland
in alice in wonderland humpty dumpty is
there and he says
here and in my world words can mean
whatever i want them to mean and alice
says
can words really mean so many things and
humpty dumpty responds and says
that is not the question the question is
what is to be master that is all the
question isn't what do the words i mean
the question is
who gets to define the words and if i
can define all the words
i can redefine reality that's the
premise that we're working on here okay
so if this is critical race theory
you're seeing it i think in its purest
form and i think
any reasonable person i know we're not
allowed to admit our faculty as a reason
we'd say we got to get rid of this stuff
some people are doing that ron desantis
in florida
is announcing that he will oppose any
candidate for school board who supports
crt
next week i have my commission on
education going to our board of
education
banning it banning any departure from
accurate history
and following our standards this is
something we've got to stay on the
forefront of
we're also dan not going to support any
republican candidate for school board
who supports critical race theory in all
67 counties
or who supports mandatory masking of
school children and so as you said these
local elections matter we're going to
get the florida political apparatus
involved
so we can make sure there's not a single
school board republican
who ever indulges critical race theory
another
home run for ron desantis here why is he
doing this
he's doing this because he knows that
the sort of
academic freedom of critical race theory
is the opposite of freedom
that actually if you permit this kind of
insanity into schools you're going to be
undermining kids education and he also
knows
that if you want to be able to
route this thing from the schools it's
not enough just to talk about it it's
not enough
just to point out the problem you have
to actually go in and win those races
and this is a very conservative very
just
use of political influence and he's
going to wield it
this can be very very effective do you
remember on this show
maybe i don't was it three four weeks
ago we talked about an
oregon school board that was infiltrated
by crazy libs
and one woman in particular wanted to
pass a rule such that in every classroom
in the school district
the teachers had to display not just the
american flag which was already in the
classrooms
but the blm flag and the progressive
pride flag just the rainbow flag i i
imagine
and it they had to be the same size as
the american flag
and they had to be there in all of the
classrooms this was just shot down we
brought some light to it on this show
a few other conservative outlets but not
very many uh pointed it out
and and this has now been shot down i
guess the parents finally took control
over their kids education and said
no i don't care what lunatic woman won
this position on the school board
we're not tolerating that we're not
going to put the blm flag on the same
level as the american flag for goodness
sakes but it's very important these
symbols really matter
sometimes people even conservatives
will criticize the cultural
conservatives for for just harping too
much on language oh who cares man it's
just a word it's just a symbol
obviously the left cares because they
focus a lot on words
and symbols and things like flags
because
the symbols shape how we perceive the
world
and the symbols represent things that
are symbolized
and what you're seeing now with this big
push to mainstream the blm flag or the
rainbow flag in particular especially
this month
is an attempt to replace the american
flag
if you look on social media sometimes
people put little flags and things and
they're in their names
when you see an american flag 99 times
out of 100 you're looking at a
conservative account
when you see a pride flag 99 times out
of 100
you're looking at a leftist account if
you see various symbols associated with
blm
you are 99 times out of 100 looking at a
leftist account this is an attempt
when you try to bring in these new flags
this is an attempt to re-found
the country this is something that they
told us in the 1619 project
they want to reframe american history
and by reframing our pest
they want to reframe the whole country
now if you need somebody new at your
workplace i would strongly recommend
ziprecruiter if you're a business owner
who's hiring you probably face
a lot of challenges when it comes to
finding the right person for your
role which is why you got to try
ziprecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com slash knowles
kennedywlis
very simple when you're hiring time is
money okay so don't waste money by just
throwing spaghetti at the wall
use ziprecruiter your job will get sent
out to over 100 top job sites with one
click but it's not going to just stay
like that
zip recruiters matching technology is
then going to go out and find people
with the right skills and experience for
your job and actively invite them to
apply
ziprecruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on
ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
within
the first day over 2.3 million
businesses have come to ziprecruiter
for their hiring needs there's a reason
for that okay while other companies
overwhelm you with
way too many options zip recruiter finds
what you're looking for that needle in
the haystack
and they find it quick right now you can
try zip recruiter for free at this web
address ziprecruiter.com
knowles kwles that is ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire
the black lives matter riots of 2020
are often credited to the 1619 project
and the woman who started the 6019
project nicole hannah jones said she was
proud to call them the 16 19 riots oh
that would be so great
because her project there was to
re-frame
american history why is this just some
academic exercise is that what this is
all about this this yale lady
who shows up to the yale school of
medicine
and she she's not she doesn't work for
yale she was brought there to give a
lecture
and she says she wants to shoot white
people in the head and white people are
incapable of reason basically they're
animals right they're like dogs
that's that's just an academic exercise
no i don't think so and
by the way in defense of yale yale did
come out and condem
the yale school of medicine came out and
condemned what this woman said but
that's sort of not the point
if if this had been in the other
direction if a white guy had gone
to the to yale and gave a lecture about
how black people are dogs
like this woman said about white people
that would not just be
a nationalist that would be an
international incident you would
have u.s senators
calling for commissions to investigate
ye i mean this would be
wall-to-wall coverage for weeks and
weeks and months and months there would
be riots in the streets over this but
then
this crazy lady comes in and says it
about white people oh oopsie yeah we
shouldn't have done that no big deal see
you later you probably won't even hear
about this story
unless you're tuned into this show or
daily wire
because it's a different set of rules
and the move here is to reframe america
as viciously racist and white
supremacist or whatever
where does this come from the idea
that america pretends to be good the
history we've been taught is that
america is good
but actually america is evil and the
only form of evil there is in the world
is racism the accusation is america
when it thinks of itself only focuses on
the good things and now we need to bring
in a corrective on the left
to focus on the bad things and a great
example of this right now
is the tulsa massacre it's a race riot
from 100 years ago in tulsa
had you ever heard about the tulsa race
riot before this year
i'm going to say probably not maybe you
did maybe you remembered reading about
it at some point but probably
probably you didn't because this is not
considered a particularly important
event in american history it's a sad
thing
but not considered particularly
important to our self-understanding
what happened in tulsa i'm sure you've
heard about it in the last week
joe biden's given speeches about it what
happened in tulsa
here are the basic facts okay and these
are the not just facts that i happen to
know
these are not just facts that i've read
in history books all of these facts
are accounted for on wikipedia a
left-wing news source
as mainstream as it gets okay in tulsa
a 19 year old black guy was accused of
assaulting
a teenage girl i think she was 17 or
something like that a white girl in an
elevator they were alone
and that was the accusation he was
arrested
and he admitted to putting his hands on
the girl but he said he didn't he didn't
assault
her so he's arrested the next day by a
white detective and a black patrolman
all right it's not just a purely white
force both of these guys come and arrest
the guy
then allegedly a sensationalist
newspaper piece
warned that there was going to be a
lynching now there's no evidence that
this newspaper piece ever existed it may
have and it might have been taken out of
the historical record we just don't know
in any case hundreds of whites show up
to the courthouse
they show up where this guy is being
held
and they were considered a possible
lynch mob there's good evidence that
they were a lynch mob
but the reason to to have worried that
they were a lynch mob is kind of ironic
the reason to have worried they were a
lynch mob is that another guy had
recently
been lynched within the previous year
but the guy wasn't a black guy was
actually a white guy who was accused of
murder
was lynched by a lynch mob also
complicates our story because
the way that we think about lynch mobs
is that they only ever go after black
people but that's not true the largest
mass lynching in american history was
against italian guys and the one the
year before the tulsa race riot was
actually a lynching of a white guy
accused of murder okay
so the white guys show up
maybe they're a lynch mob the sheriff
defends the
the teenage black guy who was accused
roland
of uh he defends him against the lynch
mob all right
hundreds then or i'm sorry first
about 60 to 80 black guys
show up worried that there's going to be
a lynch mob and they show up with
guns now at this point the hundreds of
white people there go home
and get their guns then
a shot was fired it's unclear who fired
the shot it seems likely that it was a
black guy who fired the shot
because of an incident that had taken
place between a white guy and a black
guy but it's still
unclear in any case more shots were
fired ten white guys die
two black guys die in the first little
skirmish there were more race fights the
next day
then the white mobs starts setting fire
to black businesses then things get
really out of control there are private
aircraft flying over i mean they're not
this is not like f-18s but still
private aircraft are going after black
businesses it gets crazier and crazier
and crazier
finally the national guard and law
enforcement put down this riot
numbers on the dead differ wasn't a huge
number but it was still a very very
significant riot there were
estimates range from about 10 whites
dead and 21 blackstead to about
you know 50 whites dead and 150 or so
black's dead
okay that's those are the facts in as
basic a way as i can lay out about tulsa
why do i mention this
because this sad race riot from 100
years ago is very important to america
today
no it hasn't been important until now
because the left wants to make it
important
joe biden on the 77th anniversary
of d-day right this glorious event
in our self-understanding d-day so
important
in recent memory to to america's
self-understanding
joe biden ignored d-day
he neglected it instead
he posted a video of himself meeting
with the survivors
of the tulsa race riot he says
he tweets quote i met with survivors of
the tulsa massacre this week
to help fill the silence because in
silence wounds deepen
and as painful as it is only in
remembrance do wounds heal what's he
talking about
what is he talking about i think the
wounds from the tulsa race riot had
healed
a hundred years ago the wounds that no
one was talking about at all
he's picking that scab he wants people
to focus on them
he doesn't want people to talk about
d-day that was glorious and makes
america look good he wants to talk about
this long-forgotten race riot
because that makes america look bad now
he won't talk about every race riot
he won't for instance talk about the
race riot that happened
during the summer of last year the race
riot
race i'm sorry race riots in which blm
burned down multiple cities around the
country
he's not talking about that but the but
mr president the wounds are going to
fester they're going to deepen if we
don't
no we're not allowed to talk about that
we're not allowed to talk about how blm
burned down
minneapolis and washington dc and new
york and cities
all over the country no because that
contradicts the narrative
that doesn't advance the premise that
america is a white supremacist terrible
country
actually instead of talking about those
race riots joe biden instead
meets with the family of george floyd
violates the coronavirus lockdowns
to show up to the funeral of george
floyd where many many thousands of
people were going
at the height of the apparent pandemic
he doesn't want to talk about that he
doesn't want to heal any wounds he wants
to pick wounds
because this is about framing
the way to prove this by the way is to
show it's
it's not even just about race it's
simply about
framing the country as it is as evil as
pretext for the radicals to give
revolution you saw the same thing happen
up in canada
so justin trudeau also while he was
supposed to be commemorating the 77th
anniversary of d-day
did not mention d-day it was canadian
armed services day
coinciding with d-day he doesn't mention
d-day instead he addresses quote
sexual misconduct and gender-based
violence in the military
what this is this is canadian armed
services day this is the day we're
supposed to celebrate
the armed forces of canada and their
heroic efforts now we're just going to
talk about how terrible they are
this is why now in america
we don't talk about our glories we don't
talk about
the fourth of july we don't we barely
talk about
our our veterans when we do we just talk
about them as a bunch of hapless
schmucks oh they were shipped overseas
to a pointless war they didn't it's not
as though they died for our freedom for
anything useful or purposeful
no no and we shouldn't focus on that
anyway there's memorial day and there's
pride month
you know which oh god a little bit we'll
talk about really we've got to focus on
grievance we've got to talk about
radical left
identity groups there was actually a
proposal another
day that is not has not been very
important in american history but
all of a sudden the left is trying to
make it important is juneteenth
this is one of many days that marked the
end of the civil war
but the left is trying to make this into
a really big deal and there was a
proposal by a republican senator
to make juneteenth a federal holiday but
how are they going to do it they can't
just keep making federal holidays you
know the people got to go work
so the proposal was to make juneteenth a
federal holiday to replace columbus day
so we're going to make a day that is now
largely focused on racial grievance and
pushing for the racial narrative
we're going to have that replace the
glorious day of the founding
and discovery of the new world all
about framing you know ben is going to
be talking about this crazy lady
up at yale these race issues on his show
today the real racial psychopaths
go check out and make sure you check out
candace's show okay we all love watching
candace at the daily wire
don't forget though she's also got a
podcast whether she is asking
president trump hard hitting questions
like uh whether
he wants her to hop on his ticket in
2024 whether it's getting adam corolla
to expose hollywood conservatives
or whether it's giving feminism the
roast it deserves
with her panel of guests sometimes
really handsome
swarthy witty guests i don't know i'm
just
i'm just making out an observation uh
you can check that out on canvas
subscribe to and download candace the
audio podcast on apple spotify
or wherever you get your podcast and be
sure to leave it a five star review
we'll be right back with a lot more
joe biden as the avatar of the left as a
guy who doesn't believe anything he is a
walking
talking empty suit is now fully on board
with the left's grievance narrative
specifically focused
on race but there are other grievances
as well
the reframing of our self-understanding
is away from america being a good place
pursuing good things to america being a
hopelessly evil place
destroying the world joe biden gave a
virtual commencement address
to all the students this year who didn't
go to school because of stupid policies
that people like him supported
he's giving the commencement anyway even
though these kids didn't get an
education for a year
and does he focus on the future
on all the great wonderful things on
thank your parents thank
this country that's given you so much
and go forth and do her proud no
joe biden focuses on systemic racism
and climate change
take a listen just three years after i
stood where you're standing
two of my political heroes dr king and
robert kennedy were gunned down
the vietnam war divided the nation and
divided families
we're in the midst of a great movement
for civil rights
women's rights and environmental rights
we've we faced an inflection point
and we did our best to seize that moment
because things were changing so rapidly
and now you face another inflection
point
as we put this pandemic behind us
rebuild our economy
root out systemic racism and tackle
climate change
we're addressing the great crises of our
time
with a greater sense of purpose than
ever before and because of you
your generation i've never been more
optimistic about the future than i am
today
apparently the sun monster is the same
thing
as the vietnam war you see in the 1960s
18 year old men had to go off and fight
and often die in the jungles of vietnam
and that's the same thing as you
buying a carbon tax credit or something
or eating less meat
or or turning the air conditioner down
to
turning it up i guess you know is it 68
degrees now it's gonna be like 69
degrees
to fight the sun monster you know that
big that that totally
real thing that is really threatening
all of our lives you know
not just a complete contrivance of the
radical left yeah that's the same thing
right
just like the 60s the 1960s
are the inflection point he actually
makes
an important observation here this was a
real inflection point in the country
where things basically went to hell in a
handbasket
and it was they all used this really
nice language this language that
everybody would get on board for this is
going to be better for
race relations this is going to what
we're doing right now is very important
for racial justice and for sexual
justice
and for this justice and then you think
oh i'm for all those things great
and what happened on
virtually any measure since the 1960s
things have fallen apart
the one the one measure where
people could make the argument that
things have gotten better is on race
relations
but the very people who defend the 1960s
don't make that argument they say no
actually it's not it's not better at all
than it was
actually race relations are worse it's
terri it's hidden white supremacy we got
to start shooting whites in the streets
go go to yale university you'll hear
that lecture so even on that point
they're not even making that claim the
real
turning point of the 1960s i think was
not on racial justice or sexual justice
or
environmental justice whatever that is
it's
on the shift in our self-understanding
from
loving our country and wanting to
preserve it and having gratitude for our
forebears
to despising our country and wanting to
burn it down
wasn't long after the spirit of the
sixties that you had
the reverend jesse jackson marching down
at stanford
yelling hey hey ho ho western civ has
got to go
he was referring to a specific course i
think he was also
referring to the broader civilization
hey hey ho ho western civ has got to go
used to be the glories of the past that
we want to thank and build on and
cherish to tear this
place to the ground
so what is it what are we going to do
where are we going to go from here there
is some good news
i don't want to leave you totally
sad dejected upset there is actually
good news
coming out of washington coming out of a
democrat in washington
regarding the worst piece of legislation
that's up right now
you've heard about s-1 this is the first
bill up in the senate
related to h.r one the first bill up in
the house of representatives
we've nicknamed it the corrupt
politicians act this is the bill
to federalize the elections and take
away voter integrity rules
and basically give democrats the ability
to continue to cheat in elections again
and again and again
continue to cheat because look there's
there's fraud in every election okay
uh lyndon johnson won his senate seat in
1948 because they stuffed the ballot box
okay so this sort of thing happens
it's happened in many many elections and
if the democrats get their way in the
corrupt politicians act it's going to
happen much more often
so joe manchin a swing vote he's a
moderate democrat from west virginia
he has come out and effectively said
he will not give his support to the
corrupt politicians act now it's
actually a little complicated the way
this is going to work because
in order for the corrupt politicians act
to go through
democrats need to get rid of the
filibuster which requires more than a
simple majority to get a bill through
so joe manchin wouldn't need to vote for
the corrupt politicians act necessarily
to get the act through he would just
need to vote to break the filibuster
so the question is is manchu gonna vote
to do that
and mansion says no he will not
vote for any he doesn't support the
legislation by the way
so he says voting and election reform
that is done in a partisan manner will
all but ensure
partisan divisions continue to deepen
this is something
joe manchin wrote in his hometown
newspaper
very good news i'm pleased to hear that
now there's one other swing vote that's
getting a lot of pressure right now
to uh to vote for the corrupt
politicians act that's kirsten cinema
she's in arizona that would be
we'll we'll see if she caves to that
pressure or not i hope she
she does not cave she's also fairly
independent-minded
the question we have to ask ourselves
when we're looking at something like the
corrupt politicians act is
not so much how does the constitution
lay out the way the government works in
theory the question is
where does the power really lie
when you look at the 2020 election we
know the way elections are supposed to
go
the states are supposed to make election
laws that
abide by the the rules of their state
constitutions
and then there's supposed to be certain
mechanisms in place and
a lot of that went out the window in
2020. in pennsylvania for instance
the state election officials the
democrats there threw out even the
constitutional requirements for how boat
voting be conducted
so there's the way the government works
in theory and then there's
how the government works in reality the
practice where the power really lies and
it goes beyond the government
because there are other entities that
have a lot of political power
notably the media sure but especially
big tech
big tech companies
facebook instagram youtube twitter all
of these big tech platforms acting in
concert
on january 7th and 8th censored
deplatformed ostracized the duly elected
sitting president of the united states
regardless of of what you think happened
in the 2020 election nobody can dispute
that on january 7th 2021
donald trump was the duly elected
sitting president
he had at least another 13 days left to
be president
and in that time big tech
companies hipster rasputin a grown man
with a nose ring
in silicon valley jack dorsey and the
others
censored the duly elected president
wow man that's a lot of power especially
considering
that are public square the place
politics is conducted where we speak and
we persuade one another
the essence of republican government
takes place
on those platforms those platforms
control the flow of information around
the internet and therefore around our
society
and they censored the president they had
more power than the president
trump is still off of facebook and the
facebook super duper oversight board of
the
then kicking it to the corporation and
that sounds sounds like a government
frankly like mitch mcconnell said sounds
like a parallel government
they have decided that trump will be
kicked off of facebook for another two
years
here is what the facebook spokesman said
given the gravity of the circumstances
that led to mr trump's suspension
we believe his actions constituted a
severe violation of our rules
which merit the that's bad grammar too
the via the violation is singular it
should be merits never mind i don't
expect facebook to be
particularly sophisticated i expect them
to be very powerful but not
sophisticated in their thought
a highest penalty available under the
new enforcement protocols
do you know who said this this was nick
clegg
the vice president of global affairs at
facebook he wrote that in a blog post
does the name nick clegg ring a bell
only if you pay
attention to politics overseas in the
motherland would that name ring a bell
because nick clegg
is the former deputy prime minister of
the united kingdom
he was the leader of the liberal
democrats for
seven eight years
now facebook's a private company michael
it's a private company
that is apparently run in part by a
major liberal politician in the coast
held a lot of political power
gosh these lines are starting to blur
aren't they
between the public and the private and
the politics and the culture and the
government and the business it looks
kind of all kind of looks like the same
thing to me
so now you're in a situation where a
very prominent
liberal politician is wielding a massive
ostensibly private entity to censor
conservatives
even duly elected conservatives even the
president of the united states
think about that power it's a lot of
power
but we're told by some people we cannot
question that
we're told not just by the left which is
giddily
using all of this political power
wielding it left and right
we're told by the squishy
pseudo-conservatives that we cannot
question this at all because facebook's
a private company
facebook's a private company that
employs the former deputy prime minister
of the united kingdom
and wields more power than basically any
government ever in human history and
look if they want to ostracize the duly
elected president then that's their
right that's
build your own facebook build your own
google build your own twitter
no no how because i think the end of
that is
build your own government right even
mitch mcconnell who's his establishment
as they come said that these
corporations are acting in many ways as
a parallel government
and the reason they've gotten so much of
this power in no small part is because
conservatives for the past 20 years like
lunatics
have been shilling for the corporations
that hate them
because the left has pushed for an
intense privatization of all social
decisions right sex especially sex but
so much of our culture it's private
whatever you want to do it's fine do
whatever you want chop off your body
parts if you want
and the right has pushed for an intense
privatization of all economic decisions
oh the government has nothing to say
about these giant woe corporations how
dare you these
nick clegg is a job creator we need to
defend nick clegg right no i don't think
so i think
both redounded to the same effect which
is to
upend our society and take away
political power
from the citizens
now i never thought that the united
states would have something to learn
about self-government from
nigeria but
but we do we do
on friday uh
i suppose actually a few days before
friday so sometime last week
twitter suspended the president of
nigeria they were they removed a post of
his i should say i'll be more specific
they removed a post
from president muhammadu buhari
now they removed this post because
buhari was threatening to punish groups
that
were implicated in attacks on government
buildings
and president buhari's post was removed
for violating twitter's apparent abusive
behavior policy
so it's now twitter's policy that a head
of state is not allowed to threaten to
punish groups
that attack the government
but only if the i guess only if twitter
supports those groups and opposes the
president right because there have been
certainly other times
where the situation was reversed and
twitter didn't didn't remove government
posts
so what did nigeria do they blocked
twitter from the country
they just suspended it it's now very
very difficult to get on twitter if
you're in nigeria
do you know what i say good for nigeria
now look i don't i'm not making any
point about president
muhammadu muhammadu buhari i'm not
making any point
about nigerian politics about which i
know nothing about which i don't really
care to know very much at all a lot of
countries in the world
and nigeria is trying to work out its
own situation
but i am very supportive of sovereign
states
not having their entire political system
overrun
by jack dorsey i don't think
that jack dorsey has the right to craft
national policy
in african states okay i know
that the the neolibs want this new era
of colonialism where
a handful of woke oligarchs here in the
united states
can choose every country's affairs for
them i suppose including our own
country's affairs
but i am very impressed that nigeria
said no
no twitter you violated our terms of
service and so you're not permitted in
this country
there's a lot of bad stuff on the
internet i'm not just talking about the
woke oligarchs
who are trying to take political power
away from governments whether the
governments are good governments
or bad governments the the woke
oligarchs are trying to take power
away from them and in in the case of our
country take power away
from the people but there's other bad
stuff on the internet
like only fans if you haven't heard of
only fans only fans is
a sort of democratization of porn it's
just a way to upload your own stuff
and make some i think you know only fans
gets a big cut
but then people who flash their various
body parts on the internet
can make money from people who subscribe
who are obviously
in the throes of depravity and porn
addiction because there's a lot of free
porn on the internets if you're paying
for pornography can you imagine how far
down the rabbit hole you are
so this is attracting fairly mainstream
people the former ufc
champion jessica andrade i don't know if
i'm pronouncing that correctly
she's now joining only fans she said at
the request of american fans it's always
the decadent american fans
i signed up for only fans follow me this
is bad
this is bad that people
will objectify themselves and turn
their their very bodies into a product
for mass consumption
okay that's very bad it's it's degrading
to do that sort of thing
you should that should be highly
regulated
or illegal that would not be a violation
of freedom
to make that illegal actually porn was
illegal or at least
very very heavily regulated for
basically our entire country's history
until about five minutes ago
that's good that's not an
a shrinking of free speech that is
actually a defense of free speech
because certain speech
undermines free speech certain things
undermine freedom when nigeria goes in
and suspends twitter
because twitter is suspending the
president that is not
whatever is going on in the nigerian
political system i'm just talking as a
matter of state sovereignty
that is not uh to diminish
political freedom it's to expand
political freedom
because no matter what one thinks of the
president of nigeria surely jack dorsey
is not the president of nigeria
regardless of how legitimate and just
the current ruler of nigeria is
it seems more just that be he than say
jack dorsey
right so i'm going to hear i'm going to
get
angry letters i know i'm just i'm
telling you this early
i'm going to get angry letters from
liberals and libertarians
on this point they'll say michael porn
is good it's a
you know the patriots fought the
revolutionary war to defend
women degrading themselves on only fans
you think no no that's not true
they actually explicitly wrote against
all this stuff and you're fooling
yourself if you think otherwise
[Music]
but they're going to say this is
authoritarian
it's a word that i i don't think means
very much
if it ever had a meaning these days it's
being watered down quite a lot what does
it mean
if you if you acknowledge any kind of
law if you acknowledge any kind of
self-government that's that's
authoritarian if you acknowledge that
certain speech undermines speech that's
authoritarian
no no i don't i don't think so
it's you you need limits just like a
sonnet
just like poetry poetry gets its beauty
and its freedom actually
from the limits that are imposed on it
from the meter and from the rhyme scheme
and from
various sorts of factors doesn't need to
include all of those things but there
need to be some limits to have some
poetry otherwise it's not recognizable
as a poem the same thing is true of
society the same thing is true
of speech regimes now i do want to turn
before we go to something wholesome on
the internet
abuela abuela aoc's
abuela she doesn't call her grandma she
calls her abuela
i don't refer to my grandmother as but
aoc to make a point about how much she
doesn't like america
insists on using these kind of borrowed
words every now and again
she says that abuela's roof in puerto
rico
is in disrepair aoc who is wealthy and
drives a tesla
refuses to help abuela but she's angry
and she's going to criticize donald
trump for not helping abuela even though
donald trump actually did help abuela
but corrupt puerto rican politicians
took the money
so matt walsh a true philanthropist at
the daily wire
put up a gofundme campaign and he said
we gotta help abuela
raise money to fix a roof the campaign
raised over a hundred thousand dollars
in about 10 hours
i donated okay look i know i know i'm a
philanthropist i don't know what to tell
we all
a lot of conservatives donated now
part of this is i think a lot of
conservatives knew aoc wouldn't
wouldn't permit the money to be taken
and you think that's that's exactly what
happened actually
first of all i think a lot of
conservatives gave and just thought like
okay this lady needs a roof fund
what's it to me i'm i'm i like that i
like being charitable
but a lot of us also knew aoc wouldn't
take the money
because aoc hates private charity in the
same way that bernie sanders hates
private charity
i i talk about this is philosophically
consistent with leftism i talk about
this in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words and problems which is
available now
for pre-order and you can get a signed
first edition copy premiere collectibles
so
matt gets a letter from gofundme you're
matt we're in touch with the
beneficiary's family
and they've made clear they will not be
accepting the funds raised and so now we
all get a refund
my question is does
does the family of a beneficiary get to
make that decision
because we didn't we didn't start this
gofundme
for aoc to dole out as she pleases to
abuela
the gofundme was for abuela so really
abuela should be making this decision as
far as i know aoc doesn't have power of
attorney over abuela
but someone in the family someone
powerful enough in the family to get go
wonder who that could be goes in and
says kill this thing we don't
we would rather abuela's roof be broken
than accept
a hundred grand from conservatives
because that would prove
that they're right and we're wrong and
that they're
doing a good thing and we're big jerks
about it so they
they turn it down i think someone needs
to investigate this i don't think
that aoc or anyone else in that family
has the right to do this to abuela
seems very wrong to me by the way before
we go can't i can't
let this go without mentioning it kathy
griffin tweets out on this very abuela
point to aoc says
thank you for continuing to do a great
job you represent americans better than
we represent ourselves
kathy griffin very leftist comedienne
alleged comedian
doesn't think aoc is american because
aoc is
puerto rican even though she was born in
america raised in america doesn't have
an accent
even when she uses the word abuela kathy
it sounds a little
is that racist i don't know the word
racism doesn't mean anything anymore but
i think that does that count you
represent americans better than we
represent ourselves
great little bit as far as i can tell
the tweet is still up but there's a
serious point here
kathy griffin recognizes that aoc is
anti-american and she is
she is anti-american she doesn't like
this country she doesn't like what it
stands for
she wants to fundamentally transform it
as does the left more broadly so what
kind of country are we going to have
what kind of country are we going to
have the symbols here really matter the
words we use really matter and right now
i'm sorry to say the left has the upper
hand i'm michael knowles is the michael
knowles show see you next time
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt welsh show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show